hemos hablado ya del atp y hemos dicho
que el atp en esencia es como la moneda
energética de las células verdad pero
pero quiero ahondar un poco más en ello
en este vídeo y como veremos digamos
cuando cuando vamos de atp y obtenemos a
bp y un grupo fosfato verdad que lo
representa vamos de esta forma entonces
tenemos una liberación de energía libre
verdad y de hecho por ejemplo en este en
este punto de aquí tenemos la energía
libre del atp y digamos al llevarse a
cabo la reacción y obtener el pp y el
grupo fosfato la energía libre baja
verdad la energía baja por digamos
alrededor de 30.5 kilo jules por mol
verdad y entonces si ves vídeos sobre la
energía libre verás que esta es una
reacción espontánea entonces lo que
obtenemos es que cuando la energía libre
es negativa verdad entonces estamos
hablando de
una reacción espontánea espontánea muy
bien entonces yo yo la primera vez que
vi esto me dije bueno si es espontánea
la reacción porque el atp y el agua no
sólo se vuelve a bp y libera energía y
la clave está en que tiene que pasar
está lomita que tenemos aquí gráfica da
verdad tiene que pasar esta loma tiene
digamos una energía de activación que
tiene que pasar si es que no hay una
enzima que la catálisis y la razón por
la que tenemos esta loma es porque la
forma con la que el atp se rompe es
digamos por ejemplo si tenemos aquí
nuestra molécula de agua verdad y que
está haciendo una hidrólisis lo cual es
bastante típico aunque podría hacerlo
otro tipo de molécula entonces ocurre lo
siguiente nosotros tenemos esta pareja
de electrones solitarios verdad
ok tenemos esta pareja de electrones y
deben hacer lo que nosotros llamamos
ataque núcleo físico en el fósforo muy
bien
si el ataque núcleo físico se lleva a
cabo entonces forma un enlace que es el
que he puesto aquí abajo muy bien y por
otro lado los electrones digamos de este
enlace son recuperados por este oxígeno
y eso es lo que le da la carga negativa
a este oxígeno que tenemos aquí abajo
verdad y recuerda estos electrones
solitarios verdad son negativos ya están
están aquí rodeados verdad por cargas
negativas verdad que se encuentran
también en los oxígenos así que en
esencia deben superar este hecho para
poder acercarse hacia el fósforo verdad
y eso es lo que pasa con ésta lomita que
tenemos aquí gráfica da verdad y la
forma en la que pueden hacerlo digamos
la forma en la que pueden hacerlo es con
una clase de enzimas llamadas atp asas
muy bien déjenme escribirlo por aquí se
necesita las atp asas muy bien son un
tipo especial de enzimas muy bien
recordemos que en esencia las enzimas
son
y estas proteínas verdad que se ven
todas enredadas tienen una geometría muy
complicada verdad son proteínas grandes
complejas y necesitamos además que el
atp se encuentre en el lugar correcto
para que se lleve a cabo lo que sea que
se vaya a llevar a cabo verdad y
esencialmente lo que hacen las atp asas
se rodeará la molécula de atp con iones
positivos entonces digamos vamos a poner
aquí iones positivos digamos aquí
tenemos unión positivo quizás acá habrá
otro ión positivo y de esta forma puede
mantener ocupados digamos a estos a
estas cargas negativas verdad que se
encuentran en el atp mientras la
molécula de agua va a poder digamos
reaccionar con el fósforo verdad
entonces recordemos que todo esto por
supuesto se encuentra envuelto en tres
dimensiones es verdad está en tres
dimensiones alrededor de la molécula
así entonces bueno esto que tenemos aquí
ésta es la atp asa muy bien esta es la
atp asa y al tener presente esta enzima
verdad lo que estamos haciendo es bajar
la energía de activación y entonces que
digamos pueda verse como como algo de
esta forma verdad lo que está haciendo
es disminuir la energía de activación
para que la reacción pueda llevarse a
cabo entonces en resumen la razón por la
cual no siempre vemos esta reacción es
porque hay que pasar esta loma de la
energía de activación verdad para ello
necesitaremos una enzima y así esto
permite que se lleve a cabo la reacción
y luego el agua verdad la molécula de
agua ataca al fósforo digamos forman el
enlace que teníamos aquí abajo y luego
tenemos otro hidrógeno verdad nosotros
tenemos este hidrógeno de aquí este
hidrógeno que tenemos aquí y por
supuesto éste se encontrará acá abajo lo
que ocurre es que este hidrógeno puede
ser
por otra molécula digamos por otra
molécula de agua y entonces se vuelve un
guión y drone y entonces vamos a quitar
esto de aquí de hecho eso es exactamente
lo que pasa entonces el oxígeno que
tenemos de este lado toma los electrones
del enlace y nos quedaremos digamos
ahora con este grupo fosfato verdad y
por otro lado tenemos el atp verdad
además de que hemos liberado energía ese
es digamos como la parte más importante
de todo este mecanismo ahora
generalmente uno no quiere que se libere
energía sin razón verdad la mayoría de
las atp asas lo que van a hacer es
utilizar esa energía liberada para
fósforo que fosforila a una molécula
distinta o quizás puede cambiar la
conformación de ésta atp asa para hacer
otro tipo de trabajo como cómo
transferir moléculas en contra de su
gradiente de concentración o en contra
de su gradiente quimio eléctrico o lo
que sea entonces a veces ocurre que si
se libera la energía por ejemplo en
forma de calor pero generalmente se
utiliza para algunos
otro fin útil de las células así que
espero que te haya dado una mejor idea
del atp y lo que es la hidrólisis y por
cierto se le llama hidrólisis porque al
menos en este ejemplo verdad usamos una
molécula de agua para quitar un grupo
fosfato